cada lunes como esta tarde los jóvenes
de Río se reúnen en la piedra dorsal en
el centro de la ciudad un barrio cargado
de historia símbolo de la resistencia
afro brasileña un lugar de elección para
Daniel candidata negra y transgénero soy
la primera mujer transgénero profesora y
doctora de la universidad Federal de
Daniel quiere defender la educación la
comunidad lgbtún y más los derechos de
los habitantes de las favelas pero sobre
todo más diversidad en la asamblea por
fin Alguien que nos represente porque
los otros candidatos hablan pero no
hacen nada tú lo vas a hacer porque te
conozco y lo vas a saber en Brasil Es la
primera vez que hay tantos candidatos de
la comunidad lgbtq y más en un país que
ostenta el triste record de asesinatos
de personas transgénero desde 2008 según
la ong trans anders el 40% de los
asesinatos de personas trans en el mundo
han tenido lugar en Brasil Dani Balvin
se reúne con Indiana RAE siquera que se
acompaña para ser diputada los
transgéneros son los primeros en ser
rechazados por la sociedad en ser
encarcelados así que esta violencia ya
es paralela a nuestras vidas siempre nos
ha afectado pero en un período como este
adquiere proporciones más intensas tuve
que adoptar un protocolo de seguridad
hace unos meses en la asamblea
legislativa de Río este diputado
personalista atacó a una electa
transgénero en plena sesión
parlamentaria
parece un demonio de belcebú este ser
vivo es un error de la naturaleza
atentados secuestros y hasta homicidios
de políticos la violencia política
hubiera aumentado un
335% desde la elección de Jair bolsonaro
pero a pesar de los peligros nunca ha
habido tantos candidatos representando a
minorías entre ellos son aguada
candidata indígena a diputada federal
en este momento estamos viviendo un
genocidio de los pueblos indígenas
porque la negación de nuestra tierra es
también una sentencia de muerte para
nuestra identidad
es hora de poner fin a esta violencia es
hora de poner fin a la falta de
representación indígena en los espacios
políticos
[Música]
la esperanza de Sonia crearon un grupo
parlamentario para tener más
representación en el gobierno